tummy is 18 and can no longer see but he
wasn't born blind but fujian budes
hamed's my toes inspire buried when I
was five I had an operation for a brain
tumor after the operation from one day
to the next I went blind because the
change was so abrupt i had mental
problems paranoia hallucinations it was
absolutely terrible order em come then
the house searches often be paranoia on
this mundus hideout simlish lombar so
does he hide out from and a keen on whom
to get fever in his struggle to adjust
Tommy discovered something miraculous he
could rediscover the world by clicking
his tongue yeah our formula isn't kind
yes there's a circle in front of me
about a meter away dan come then comes a
rectangle about 50 centimeters away
sending me Dan fant yeah and about two
meters away as a triangle I egg dim
bamboo or if death might all at some
point I started clicking around outside
without even my stick I experimented a
lot even though I didn't really want to
at first and then when I found out that
I could do it was so cool Abaddon
hoffman's doctora on man bad and june
summers ecuador a ver mandas condo using
sonar for orientation as a
well-established phenomenon in the
animal world bats use it to navigate in
twilight and darkness with absolute
accuracy it prevents accidents Tommy
copies the bats and is just as
successful he clicks and the echo shows
him the path ahead is it curved or does
it have corners is there enough
headspace is he approaching stairs this
click sonars valve in lehighton it for
me clicks owner changed everything i
could suddenly do so much more by myself
i became more independent of all outside
now I can go out with my dog I here
where walls I'm I can avoid getting too
close to them sell my clothes don't get
damaged any niche to dish and my wine
lankier by this is here and hide all
feeling good filly klamotten Wendy
didn't hide video Kotkin
every sound creates an echo that is
reflected by every object the quicker
the echo comes back the nearer the
object is
loja tada has been studying click sonar
techniques for many years she collects
reports of the experiences that the
blind people who use it have they showed
that echoes don't only provide
information on distances but also data
about the immediate environment like
whether the blind person is facing a
filled with lots of grass or a concrete
wall or whether an obstacle is made of
plastic or wood
what happens in the brain when a human
being creates a picture of their
environment using sounds Tala uses
magnetic resonance imaging to record
which parts of the brain are activated
he puzzled a sternum scanner on this
patients lie in the scanner and we play
them the pre-recorded sounds disputed
and in for the patient's then tell us
what they're here for instance they
might say that's a tree that's a car
that's a building and their association
is almost always correct we use neutral
control sounds to verify this and those
don't provoke any associations good boy
Beethoven we're going to contour and
damali decent formats your own niche
Terry the result is surprising using
echolocation restructures a blind
person's brain the scene does buzon de
Anthony Gibbon what's special about
these results is that blind people who
use clicks ona techniques indicate
extremely strong activity in that part
of the brain where sighted people
process visual stimuli so sounds are
processed in the visual center and do
indeed create pictures in the head even
though the patient is unable to see
as would any sunglasses on the ad as
that's food I wouldn't go so far as to
say that it's a substitute for real
sight yeah does this but the brain makes
use of a capability we all possess build
you don't need to be a super brain to be
able to do it anyone can learn it as a
man was kind super gear on Honda's
chronometer Connie's Tommy clicks his
way confidently to the Baker's he can't
make out the different kinds of cake but
that doesn't bother him he feels free
independent and strong almost like any
other 18 year old